esta vez tenemos la siguiente expresión
cuatro por un millón más tres por mil 67
x
milésima
como haremos esto será que primero
multiplico cuatro por un millón y luego
le sumo tres y después todo eso lo
multiplicó por mil o como funciona y
para que esto lo tengamos claro tenemos
que recordar el orden de las operaciones
en este caso el orden de las operaciones
nos indica que si tenemos
multiplicaciones y sumas en un enunciado
así o en una expresión así lo primero
que haremos son las multiplicaciones y
para que eso lo tengamos claro vamos a
poner unos paréntesis indicando aquí que
primero haremos las multiplicaciones que
se encuentran dentro y posteriormente
haremos las sumas
vamos uno por uno que tal cuatro por un
millón esto realmente nos indica cuatro
millones
1 2 3 4 5 6 4 millones ahora tendremos
tres por mil tres por mil es igual a
tres mil
y tenemos 67 por un milésimo es igual a
67 milésimos hasta ahí vamos bien pero
también podemos representar este 67
milésimas como
60 milésimas
siete mil décimos
y 60.000 décimos son
6 centésimos
centésimos lo pondré en este otro color
así es que podemos decir que tenemos 67
milésimos o 6 centésimas más siete
milésimas vamos a hacer las sumas
tenemos entonces cuatro millones lo
colocaremos en el lugar de los cuatro
millones
tenemos centenas de millar no decenas de
millar no pero si tenemos unidades de
millar tres mil 4 millones tres mil
seguimos avanzando tenemos centenas no
decenas no unidades
tampoco de hecho ni siquiera tenemos
décimas
pondremos 0 en el lugar de las décimas
tenemos centésimas y aquí están nuestras
centésimas colocaremos entonces 6
centésimas y tenemos milésimas
también tenemos siete milésimas así es
que esta es la representación en
decimales de nuestra expresión original
tenemos cuatro millones tres mil con 67
milésimas o lo que es lo mismo cuatro
millones tres mil seis centésimas con
siete milésimas